hi herzlich willkommen zum heutigen
video leute ich bin dir zusammen mit
escape cds und wir spielen heute eine
folge mutig ist das haben wir bereits
für sebastian gemacht müsst ihr euch
auch anschauen linke ist und mit dem
schreiben aber erstmal bleibt die bitte
dran denn ich mir heute nicht einfach
nur weiter mutig nein nein
bist wohl shareware ja was machen wollte
kraft ich habe mir was einem start und
zwar diese wasserbombe was sie macht
demonstrieren und wie man diesen ich
muss jetzt einmal demonstrieren
man lebt hier auf einen knopf und dann
fängt sie an zu tippen und lande
gewissen zeit keiner weiß wie lange
diese wasserbomben aus hier oben wasser
bespritzt
nein wirklich nicht ab acht jahren immer
noch hier sind jetzt zb eingeblendet
eine blume und eine sonne und drunter
als täte es ist eine pflanze das hier
zum beispiel lieber es kay wäre eine
sonnenblume als es immer so dass
passwörter in dem autos ausgedrückt sind
machen muss welches wort diese
ausdrücken wieder auf und die
schwierigkeit liegt darin dass hier
einer dem anderen lernt er überlegt die
wasserbomben vors gesicht hält das sage
ich sofort und erwirtschaften stellt
wenn man das wort richtige hat davon die
bombe weitergeben und das ist anderen er
die 2000 geht so hoch ganz genau was ja
3 2 1
das hier ist ein kredit resonanz
insbesondere
auch ihren bars mein gesicht nicht
reicht muss man aber auch deshalb ein
langes warten in new york war schön kurz
das heißt aber dass nicht noch mal boxen
sondern es geht mir wieder weil ich habe
es ja eigentlich erwarten nein alles
klar ich starte wieder und 321 okay das
ist ihr alle da die thc nächstes level
wollte man sich aber nicht ständig aber
folgendes ich habe krebs bekommen werden
oder wärst du drauf bekommt also ich
höre ich hoffe mal das ist kennedy
chruschtschow spiel und kennen die
paperworld vertippt das ist tödlich
jungen das nicht will aber du hast
richtig herausgezögert so dass ich
wieder abbekommen dankeschön es okay
geschenk erkrankung niemals einfach mal
weiter und krieg direkt die nächste
aufgabe sebastian brück bitte ok das ist
ja wie verbreitet das schöne sachen die
bombe blutiger hallo pizza viel
okay gewesen
aber was jetzt für sebastian wieder an
okay das war für uns dass wir seitdem
klappt das mit cleveren dass ich mich ob
man mutter wird trotzdem voll
ausschreiben konzentriere was ist denn
los mit mir das stativ ist total dass
die bahn zu inzwischen hat ist gute idee
dieses wie 43 28 16 projekte besser denn
die feuerwehr level 10 wir kommen
relativ gut durch und kappt preise da
das nicht okay ich bin nicht böse
ekstraklasa wird das thema natürlich hat
mir geholfen diesmal das duo über die
rechte ganz romantisch
worauf sein da mond laufen
das schlimmste was das stadion ist fern
ab sofort von risiken als partner wer
jetzt dachte das ist sein motto
66 aber das dauert ja einer halben
stunde ist ein zu geben wir machen
weiterhin 32
das war für mich wie youtube youtube
diese city der orthopädietechnik ich
ziehe jetzt aber wenn die cockpits wenn
der gesuchte und es geht weiter
ja wahrscheinlich war ich geschockt
nein aber es ist so schnell geht ich
habe bei mir stellt
junge wp stewart ist mein gott oh mein
gott warum ist locker teil der planer
wie kann das sein
deswegen nicht übermäßig hoch schauen
mal was hier ist band übernahme von dem
die rede
angry birds ist übrigens ein gutes
stichwort denn wir höchstwahrscheinlich
bist ich hab schon gar nicht mehr gesagt
ist dieses video ein werbevideo für
google play oder etwa der playsport
kampagne wenn im fall kurse ab spiele
zocken will schenkt vorbei und sagen
dass dieses spiels und außerdem wenn ihr
mehr davon sehen wird man im mobile
gaming jetzt eine abstimmung es geht mir
so was macht einfach weiter letzter
klar ist was ist euer herz mit weiter
geht es zur typs guten also schwitzt
nicht das kann ich gar nicht eingehen
aber leute ich würde auch sagen man soll
aufhören wenn es am schönsten ist ich
will es mal am schönsten du auch 100
meter ausgebaut deswegen schöner
zeitpunkt dann würde ich sagen wenn wir
jetzt auch noch dicker machen vor an der
umfrage teilnehmen und zwar ob ihr bock
auf mehr mobile gehen ich hab klick
darauf dass kleine ionen der ecke
ansonsten check die andere mobile gaming
videoserver sc freiburg
sanremo tigris gezeigt haben dann sehen
wir mal nicht mal wieder ohne sie